hey youtubers is Charlie since a lot of
guardians of the galaxy stuff is
dropping right now I thought it'd be fun
to take one of the really cool
characters from the movie and do a
breakdown of them so this video is gonna
be all about Ronan the accuser there was
also some news about the Hulk may be
doing a team-up movie with the guardians
out in space during phase 3 so I'll
explain what's going on with that - real
quick hello to all the new people if
you're just finding me for the first
time I do Marvel and DC stuff every week
be sure to subscribe to get it
guardians is the next big thing coming
but I try to rotate between Avengers and
spin-off movies so because the Hulk
phase 3 stuff is what everyone's going
crazy about right now I'll do that first
it's pretty straightforward a couple of
new sites are reporting that instead of
a standalone Hulk film in Phase three
Marvel will just use Mark Ruffalo with
another team right now the only other
big movie team is the Guardian so he go
from The Avengers to the space Avengers
even though the actual Avengers go into
space all the time in the comics
everyone at Marvel totally loves Mark
Ruffalo and his version of the Hulk
he's just been saying in interviews that
they're not quite ready for another mega
solo movie but they do want to do
another non Avengers Hulk movie which
means team-up and I think that because
the Hulk character is so rich with
comedy like at the end of Avengers
whenever he punched Thor he worked
really really well in a movie driven
more by comedies like guardians of the
galaxy he's not gonna be in any post
credits for the first guardians movie or
anything this would be for the Knicks
guardians movie in phase 3 there's no
date for that right now but the way
they're getting Hulk into space
sounds like a modified version of Planet
Hulk so here we have to talk about a
bunch of Avengers - rumors but because
of a Guardians Hulk team-up it sounds
pretty plausible so careful for
potential spoilers for the end of
Avengers 2
you can totally turn the volume down for
about a minute so I'll just wait a
second
everybody ready okay here we go okay so
supposedly at the end of Avengers the
solution to Ultron is that they can't
kill him so in order to solve the
problem they pull a Planet Hulk and
shoot him into deep space in a spaceship
that's meant to double as a prison Hulk
is the one that fights him and gets him
onto the ship but as a result gets stuck
as the ship is leaving orbit and because
he doesn't have the Homer Simpson you
know fat-fingered Eiling wand he gets
stuck going into deep space - if you
haven't read it you should totally check
out the Planet Hulk comic book they
turned it into a cartoon movie - it's
one of the best
stories in the last 10 years so real
quick let me know in the comments what
do you think about the idea of a
guardians of the galaxy Hulk team-up I
know we haven't even seen their first
movie yet but I'm really optimistic that
it's gonna be great and I like the idea
of the hook being like a journeyman
character in the Marvel Universe in the
movie universe so now that we're talking
about guardians let's move on to Ronan
the accuser he's being played by Lee
pace if you can't tell by all the blue
Kree makeup he's gonna be the main
villain of the movie I know we've got
Bannos in the collector to even bigger
characters but supposedly the collector
is going to be more of a neutral figure
and Thanos is only showing up in Hollow
Communications like he'll be galactic
skyping Ronan nebula and Korath so who
is Ronan the accuser he's basically a
Kree soldier who's the leader of the
accuser Corps they're basically the Kree
space militia they're like the Kree
version of the Nova Corps he considers
the xandarians the race that originated
the Nova Corps to be his mortal enemies
so whenever you see Kree ships
descending on Xandar in the trailer
that's Ronan's accuser Corps attacking
the planet so Ryan isn't necessarily a
villain per se it's just that his goals
of eliminating his enemies the
xandarians caused him to form an
alliance with Thanos in the movie he's
the true villain of the story and
because the guardians are the
protagonists in this movie Ronan by
aligning himself with evil is a villain
by circumstance but that doesn't mean
that whenever he pops up in future
movies he's still gonna be a villain
he's like a Loki character that can
bounce back and forth there have been
times in the comics where he teams up
with Peter quill in the Nova Corps and
he even teamed up with Thor in the
avengers last year during Marvel's
infinity storyline it was really cool
Ronan has this crazy devotion to the
people he loves and krystal his wife in
the comics so he's willing to do
anything to protect them and her
sometimes that means aligning himself
with heroes and sometimes with villains
so whenever you see him in the movie
expect him to come off as more of an
antihero or a villain of circumstance
he's still a little bit crazy but he's
not evil that doesn't mean that he and
his teammates karen gillan digimon
Honsou won't tear up though in the
Kree Empire he's second only to the
Supreme intelligence that character is
not supposed to be in the movie or at
least it hasn't been confirmed most of
the Kree we see are blue skinned but
those are just the upper class Kree
Ronan is like an aristocrat in his
society which makes him even more of a
dick I don't expect the movie to go too
deep into the inner workings of the
Korean
Peyer but in the Nova comics he's had a
lot of political intrigue thriller
stories the trailers in this movie are
really showing him off with his hammer
so I think he's gonna spend equal
amounts of time speechifying and
smashing stuff I have seen a lot of you
guys speculate that because his hammer
glows purple in the trailers that it's
somehow connected to one of the infinity
gems that would have to be the space gem
just because that's the purple gem if
you're not familiar with that one it's
the one that gives the user the ability
to manipulate space as in travel so
it'll teleport you anywhere you want to
go that's actually not what's going on
his hammer in the trailer is just his
Universal weapon that's what it's called
the universal weapon it's the most
powerful handheld weapon the Kree have
it's similar to Thor's hammer it can
create force fields energy blast and it
gives wrote in the ability to fly it
also has some cool cosmic properties
that allow him to transmute matter so
I'm expecting him to war up a bunch of
stuff in the movie it also has some cool
safety mechanisms like Thor's hammer to
Thor's hammer can only be used by
someone deemed worthy
according to aden standards Captain
America is one of the few people besides
Thor and Odin that have actually been
able to use it in the comics Ronan's
hammer can only be used by a Kree
soldier wearing the cybernetic armor
that you see him wearing in the trailer
if you tried to pick it up and you
weren't a Kree wearing that special
armor you'd be shocked to death and
another big difference between Ronan's
weapon and Thor's hammer is that there's
only one Mjolnir there are actually many
versions of Ronan's hammer he just has
the most powerful one so the hammer does
have properties that mimic some of the
infinity gems powers but it's not
powered by a gem I think that the orb
that Peter quill is trying to steal in
the trailers is the actual gem the space
gem and yes I do think this movie is
going to revolve around in infinity gem
remember as we progress through each
Marvel movie we have to establish all
six of the gems so that whenever we get
to Avengers 3 we can do Infinity
Gauntlet Marvel has done a few times why
methinks with the way they're talking
about the gems they're not actually
describing them as physical gems I don't
have that big speech during the dark
world we said some of them appear as
artifacts I've even heard stories that
they're calling that tesseract one of
the gems in the comics that's totally
not the case the cube is supposed to be
a container for an unknown power source
that slowly gained sentience and
eventually it imposes its will on people
that wield it they did kind of tease
this in the first Avengers movie with
the
you saying things to Hawkeye and Loki so
for now let's assume that the cube is
not one of the gems but Ronan is
basically chasing Peter quill through
the movie to get the orb for Thanos
that's the bargain that Ronan makes give
fan oohs the orb
Thanos destroys the xandarians his
mortal enemies so in the trailers
whenever you see Djimon Honsou going
after chris pratt he's playing Korath
he's essentially working for ronan to
get that orb so I'm really hoping that
the movie leaves the Ronan character in
a place whereby he can team up with the
Guardians in a future movie they don't
have to be best friends or anything you
know even Glenn Close and john c reilly
of the nova corps think they're a bunch
of galactic but because we
haven't even seen the first movie is a
little too early to speculate on what
the second movie might be about
definitely another Thanos centric story
but we're just starting to do
space-based movies so there's almost too
many options usually sequels go deeper
into stories involving cool sight
characters like Michael Rooker's yondu
he's more of a space pirate in this
first Guardians movie but I could
totally see them introducing the Nova
character in a future sequel I know
everyone was expecting Nathan Fillion to
play him in this movie but that's not
the case I do expect to see some Nova
Easter eggs and add to that if they end
up making the sequel movie a whole
crossover imagine him fighting Thanos
they actually did that last year in the
comics but in reality I don't think
anyone's gonna meet Thanos in physical
combat til Avengers 3 until then he's
gonna be like the Emperor and star wars
just sitting above it all watching
everyone dance around so now it's your
turn let me know do you think we'll ever
see a Ronan the accuser team up with the
guardians of the galaxy and do you
believe the rumors about the Hulk
crossover with the Guardians I think
it's totally possible I definitely would
like to see Ally pace guardians of the
galaxy team up if you do want to see
more Lee pace and you've watched
desolation like a billion times
you should watch halt and catch fire
he's not wearing any makeup in it but
it's still pretty cool so I will be
doing more Guardians bonus videos in the
next couple of weeks
be sure to let me know which characters
you want me to talk about I might do
Karen Gillan nixed she's playing nebula
in this movie so I cannot wait to see
her kick some ass be sure to subscribe
to get that I was really sad to see her
leave Doctor Who but I'm so happy that
she's doing all these big movies now so
click here if you want to learn more
story rumors about Avengers 2 and click
here to get my breakdown of the last
Guardians trailer thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
advice
you